a lot about this week on this show is
early voting
over 85 million people have already cast
their ballots which is more than 60
of the total number of americans who
have voted four years ago
and they did so while worrying about a
pandemic that has killed more than 230
000 of their fellow americans part of
why the pandemic has been so bad in this
country
is that we haven't done enough to find
the virus
and stop the spread now those two
stories
early voting and coronavirus testing are
colliding
actor sean penn has been running a group
that offers free covet testing in
counties
all across the country this group called
core
has been set up by at state farm arena
in atlanta
which happens to be georgia's largest
voting center
sean penn and core are working to make
american civic duty
a safe one by offering voters a chance
to take a test
poor is repeatedly one of the one of
reportedly one of the largest
if not the largest cova testing program
in the entire united states and joining
me now is sean penn two-time oscar
winner
and the co-founder of core community
organized relief effort
and jonathan golden who is coors atlanta
program manager i'm so happy to chat
with you
about this an important topic sean i
want to start with you
i'd like to ask you about why
you chose these specific sites to offer
free copic testing
you know going back to the beginning of
the pandemic you have 42
testing locations across the country how
did you select
where you wanted to go well initially it
really had to do with where the
partnerships were we weren't looking to
reinvent the wheel of community
leadership we were looking to partner
with community leadership
and with local governance in the case of
fulton county uh in georgia
initially there was a lot of resistance
to us coming into georgia
but then when we started working
directly with the
with the mayor of atlanta and fulton
county uh we found that we had
a very strong bipartisan partnership
um um within fulton county uh
people with good who really had the
force of will and the political will
to to get involved and do this so it's
really been about where we could
identify partners and be able to get
in particular to the most marginalized
communities and and those that were
being most affected by the virus
absolutely and testing is such a
critical component we've watched other
countries around the world
you know scale up their testing programs
and i'm almost envious in a way
when i see that what's happening in
south korea and elsewhere jonathan have
you seen more people
coming through your testing sites in
atlanta uh because of
early voting this is such a critical
component to coronavirus response
yes absolutely you know what we can
offer here in atlanta it's
safe farm is a one-stop shop as someone
who came by
referred to as within 15 minutes you can
test you can vaccinate and you can vote
and after the first day of that word got
out and you know numbers are climbing
and climbing and climbing
by the end of it after about a week long
period we're able to
you know test over you know test
thousands of individuals at state farm
and vaccinate hundreds as well so word
got out it's a one-stop shop
and that definitely did drive numbers
i would want to go somewhere where i
could get all of those things too
in one place go ahead sean just to be
clear the vaccinations he's talking
about is for the flu which we know is
really necessary at this time don't
cross over and surge
capacity but what we are hoping to do
and and and and aiming for is our
uh belief in the uh in what may be the
next
the next administration's uh policies on
this
is to be ready to to be a
a partner uh implementer with the with
with a biden administration
uh at the moment we underst we see that
the
uh trump administration is in pandemic
denial
um and it has been a devastation
and has directly led to um
hundreds of thousands of american deaths
and so
what we're hoping to do is being able to
fold over and eventually
these sites may be maybe able to be used
along with the cold chain necessities
uh to vaccinate for covid once the
vaccine comes online
on that first day of early voting
jonathan when there were long lines um
at state farm arena did that impact your
covet testing site
and how are things going uh today
yeah so we we work very closely with the
atlanta fulton county emergency
management agency board of health and
state farm arena to find the best
location
what we don't want to do is you know
attract positive individuals from around
the county and have them interact too
closely
with these long lines so steps were
taken there was
you know social distancing and force for
all the lines master giving out masks
we're wearing
were worn and then our are voting our
covet and flu vaccine site
was in a separate area visible from the
entrance so those individuals who just
wanted to vote and not go through
testing had a different route
but testing was visible so they could
interact with the testing beforehand or
afterwards
that sounds good shawna you and jose
andres penned an op-ed together
calling for the president to embody his
self-proclaimed title
at the beginning of this president at
the beginning of this pandemic as a
wartime president
and you know you asked him to work with
congress to bring americans financial
relief
as we know that hasn't happened at least
in the second
uh portion of the relief that needs to
go to american citizens is someone who's
been on the ground for for many
catastrophes uh and
uh tragedies what are you seeing that
led
what are you seeing in this specific
situation that led you to write
this piece this is
a level of incompetence be it on a
political level or on a human level
that few of us have ever seen that work
in any kind of
crisis this is one of the things that i
i
i just don't understand about where we
are as a country where
where the those who support the
president
are not able to see that that not only
is it covet
that makes us vulnerable it's virtually
any crisis
facing this president and his
administration
will be met with a level of incompetence
that will cost lives and and then on top
of that to fuel the vitriol
uh in ways that are so against any kind
of kindness of spirit
or spiritual belief or care it's
it's been a level of
political obscenity like i've
never seen before
i haven't ever seen it before either in
my lifetime sean you're also the focus
of a
new documentary called citizen pen about
your work in disaster
zones like in haiti after the horrible
earthquake
what do you want people to know about
why you've chosen to take on so many
humanitarian
disasters in your work you know i i
think that
even if and i pray win um
joe biden and kamala harris uh take the
white house
people have to know that government
doesn't work
without citizen participation uh we
really you know there are so many
there's a
there's a saying that we're not looking
for a savior we're looking for a bridge
and this this what could be this new
administration might be that bridge and
and and with that
bridge we still need to keep politicians
feet to the fire
we still need to get involved and do
whatever we can do
each to uh with our own resources and
really participate
when when when when there's partnership
in disaster zones
when there's leadership in disaster
zones it's still a long hard
fight but you you get there you see it
happening
and every single person can take
ownership in that
sean in our final minute i'm curious if
you have any predictions
on for election night or election day
what are you
looking to to see happen and what are
you excited about happening
well it is my hope that the best
of what we all are as americans i think
that
it may surprise some that i consider
myself a census
and i have a great respect and affection
for many of my
conservative friends as well and i i
think that when we look across the
country
that we'll wake up on that morning of
course
we don't think it's going to be just one
morning but we'll wake up on that
morning and remember that we're one
and and listen to each other
that's my hope absolutely that's a i
hope that too
um i hope that we um can try to support
each other and protect each other that's
why masks are great because
a mass protects me but it also protects
everyone that i come into contact with
sean penn and jonathan golden thank you
so much and thank you for the work that
you're doing